MIKE COLEMAN: Hi.
I'm Mike Coleman, a developer
advocate at Google Cloud.
Many years back my friend
Keith and I were replacing
a blown head gasket on my car.
I went to remove a bolt
with an adjustable wrench.
And Keith stopped me
cold in my tracks.
He then said something
that has stuck with me ever
since, "Always use the
right tool for the job,"
as he handed me
a inappropriately
sized box wrench.
We are seeing this
advice play out today
in the way organizations
are leveraging the cloud.
They are choosing
different cloud providers
for different workloads
based on a variety of factors
in an effort to ensure they
are using the right tool
for the job at hand.
However, using multiple
cloud providers
comes with added complexity in
the form of multiple management
interfaces, disparate
policy enforcement,
and complex security
implications.
In this video, I
want to talk a bit
about how Anthos can help
reduce the complexity
around multicloud
Kubernetes deployments
with a very specific focus
on Microsoft's Azure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before we move into
Anthos on Azure,
let's talk about Anthos
in more general terms.
Anthos provides a
unified platform
for managing Kubernetes clusters
across different clouds,
as well as on prem.
These clusters can
be running inside
of virtual machines
and instances,
as well as on bare metal.
Anthos is comprised of an
integrated set of services
developed to ensure the entire
IT organization-- operators,
developers, security teams--
can accomplish their duties
without a siloed approach.
Anthos is made up of several
different components,
such as container management.
Anthos provides a
reliable and efficient way
to deploy and run containers.
Service management, Anthos
features a managed service mesh
offering to connect, manage
and secure VMs and containers.
Policy management,
Anthos Config Management
provides a central
place to manage
configuration and
security policies
across your entire fleet.
Operations management,
Anthos is integrated
with cloud logging
and cloud monitoring
to provide an integrated
logging and monitoring
service for containers,
services, and application.
Specific to multicloud,
Anthos allows
you to manage clusters on
Google Cloud, AWS, and Azure.
Now let's dive a little
deeper into Anthos on Azure.
When you deploy an
Anthos on Azure cluster,
you end up running a
compliant Kubernetes cluster
on Azure native resources.
This cluster can be accessed
via the Cloud Console,
gcloud command line, or kubectl,
just like any other Kubernetes
cluster.
Additionally, as we'll
see in the demo later,
the cluster will show up
alongside clusters provisioned
in other environments,
such as Google Cloud, AWS,
or bare metal inside of
the Google Cloud console.
The Anthos on Azure
architecture is comprised
of several components.
The first is a
multicloud cluster API.
This is a standard
Google Cloud REST
API, which provides
cluster CRUD operations.
Several Azure
specific parameters
are passed, such as the
subscription ID, the VNet ID,
and the subnet ID, along with
parameters for the cluster size
and configuration.
Next, we have the multicloud
cluster controller.
When a cluster is created using
the Anthos multicloud API,
a long running operation
is created with the Google
Cloud-based cluster controller.
This controller will
create the cluster in Azure
asynchronously.
You can check the
status of the cluster
operation via a Get-Cluster
call to the API.
Next, we have Anthos
service account.
Once the Anthos multicloud API
is enabled on your Google Cloud
project, a Google
managed service account
will be automatically
created within your project.
This service account will
be the security principle
calling the Azure APIs.
Additionally, we have the
Anthos app registration.
In order for the
cluster controller
to create Azure resources
within your subscription using
the Anthos service account, an
Azure application registration
must be created within the
Azure Active Directory.
Finally, there's
the Connect API.
In order to integrate into
the Google Cloud console,
a Connect agent
running on the cluster
makes an outbound TLS
call to the Connect API.
In any cloud environment there
are multiple different types
of resources.
Deploying Anthos
is no different.
However, because Anthos
automates the lifecycle
of the cluster, some resources
are managed by Anthos,
while others are managed by you.
Well, now that you have
an understanding of how
Anthos on Azure clusters
are built and managed,
let's take a look
at a quick demo
to give you a firsthand look
at how it all comes together.
The first thing
I'm going to do is
create what we're
calling a client, which
is a set of credentials
that we can use to operate
against our Azure resources.
So I've created that client.
Now I'm going to go ahead
and export the certificate.
I'm going to take
that certificate.
And I'm going to
upload it into Azure.
So let's move into
the Azure console.
And I'll come over
here, and I'll
click on Certificates
and Secrets.
And then I'll do
Upload Certificate.
And I'll choose that certificate
that we just created.
Come down here.
I'll click the Add button.
And I now have that
certificate uploaded.
And I can authenticate
against those Azure resources.
Now let's go ahead and create
our control plane cluster.
You'll notice here that I'm
actually specifying things
like the Azure subnet ID, the VM
size that's specific to Azure,
so a bunch of Azure
specific parameters.
After a few minutes that
cluster will be created.
So let's wait for it to finish.
There it is.
So we've got the control
plane up and running.
Now let's go ahead
and add the node pool.
So a lot like the last
command, when we issue this,
we'll put in some Azure
specific parameters
to create that node pool.
So we'll give that
a couple of minutes.
Fast forward the video,
and that node pool
will be created as well.
Now, if we move up
to the Azure console,
we can actually see
all those resources
we just created using gcloud.
So using the Google command
line, we were able to go in
and provision things like
NICs, and VMs, IP addresses,
load balancers, all of
those Azure resources.
Now, if we want the cluster
to show up in Google Cloud,
we need to create
a hub membership.
So we'll create
the hub membership.
And we'll install the Connect
agent on that cluster.
And that will allow it to show
back up in the Google Cloud
console.
So if I move over there,
there's our cluster.
So if I click on the
name, you can get details
about the cluster.
We can go up, and then
click on the nodes.
We can explore
the details there.
And again, these
are the same VMs
that we saw running
in the Azure console.
And if I come up to storage,
you can actually even see
the names of those disks.
And you can see like,
disk.csi.azure.com.
And those are Azure resources.
Now, I don't have any
workloads running,
just that Connect agent
I installed earlier.
So let me do a quick deployment
of a microservices demo.
So we'll do the Kubernetes
deployment YAML here,
create a bunch of services.
We'll move back.
We'll refresh our workloads.
Notice how we're
using the Google Cloud
console to look at the
workloads running up in Azure.
So that's that
single pane of glass.
So they're not all running yet.
Refresh.
Give it a second, and
everything's up and running.
Now, if I move over
here and I click
on the left on
Services & Ingress,
I can find the IP address of
the Azure base load balancer.
And I can click on that.
And we'll see our
application running.
So we'll click here.
There's the application
running on Kubernetes, deployed
from Google Cloud into Azure.
Well, there you have it.
That's Anthos on Azure.
For additional information,
check out the links below.
And don't forget to like and
subscribe to be alerted when
we create fresh new content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]